welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and this video we're
breaking down fast and the furious
in space the ninth movie in the dom
cornetto saga is here
and throughout this video we'll be
breaking down the plot and the
post-credits scene to discuss
what could be coming next time full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check the movie out then i
highly recommend that you slam the
brakes on this year breakdown
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
it and don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into fast 9.
now i am going to be breaking down the
general plot of the movie first and then
talking about the ending and post
credits scene before heading into the
review part of the video
time codes are below if you want to race
ahead but i feel like we need to talk
about the plot points before we talk
about how they set up the ending
now as always we follow dom toretto
played by a man who loves cars so much
that his name is almost van diesel the
movie picks up in 1989
and as always family takes a big
spotlight as we meet not only jack off
the track toretto
but also his brother jacob now we
haven't seen him through the series at
all
which is fitting as he's played by none
other than john cena
jacob becomes the overarching villain of
the piece i'm glad that the fast
franchise has got to the point that
there's so much family
even the bad guys are family there is
very much this idea of fathers and sons
laced throughout the film and dom's son
little brian will no doubt be joining
the team
as soon as he's old enough to get his
provisional now we learn that jack
was in debt up to his eyeballs and thus
he turned to jacob to help throw the
race
jacob put a crack in the fuel line and
unfortunately this caused the car to
explode
which killed their father in the process
we learned a rival racer when to pay his
respects
but things got out of hand and dom ended
up beating the crap out of him
which landed him in prison jacob took to
the streets
and in jail dom learned that his brother
probably caused his father's death
after his release dom challenged his
brother to a race and after he lost he
forced him to head out into the world
and make a life for himself
obviously the the first thing you would
do when when hit with this scenario is
become a super spy secret agent
and judas cena's powers to turn
invisible we learn that he's one of the
most deadly assassins in the world
he's also funded by the son of a
dictator known as otto
and he becomes one of the main
antagonists too now otto wants to take
over the world
and this can be accomplished by a piece
of tech named after the god of war
ares jacob steals it from mr nobody and
the movie really kicks it up a gear when
the fast family go to investigate the
disappearance of nobody
and find nobody thank you i'm here all
week now the series jumps to shark and
across the bridge at points
but overall i found it a really fun ride
that has several appearances by
characters that drive like my grandma
the group travel the world as they
attempt to track jacob down and along
the way they find out that han
is actually alive now one of the biggest
mysteries surrounding the movie
is why did they do so many star wars
metaphors
and not do a hand solo joke however on
top of that there's also another big one
which is how is hans still alive now the
character last appeared in fast and the
furious 6
where he apparently died at the hands of
decade shaw now it turns out that
after the death of giselle the character
actually enlisted into the ranks of mr
nobody
han was actually based in tokyo and we
learned that he was sent by nobody in
order to get ares
here he came face to face with otto and
jacob's team
who murdered the inventor of the weapon
and his wife leaving just their daughter
alive
and killed the team and took her in but
nobody had to fake his death so that the
pair could lie low
and says that mr nobody had a way of
making things look real
and this the explosion was a facade with
say with me
no body hey now we never look terrible
now we
so bad now we never learn exactly how
this was pulled off
but we do get a line saying it's a
pretty nifty magic trick so it's likely
done with smoke mirrors and projections
if you go back and watch the sixth film
then he's clearly in the car
but come on guys there's a car hanging
off a rope in this film
just turn your brain off now it turns
out that aries is encrypted to the
daughter of the inventors dna
l and she ends up being kidnapped by
jacob which leads to a big showdown
on board a convoy jacob and otto's team
try and upload ares to a satellite
in order to take over every electronic
device in the world
or something along those lines it's it's
it's a bit ambiguous now there's fire
water air and dirt [ __ ] magnets how
do they work and it leads to a big chase
between some of dom's crew on the ground
whilst tej and roman head out into space
to take down the satellite that the info
is being sent to
though jacob had cypher held in prison
at otto's base she manages to talk her
way out of it
and ends up joining forces with the
ladder they betray jacob mid mission
and he ends up joining his brother in
order to stop aries and the convoy
carrying it
cipher tries to kill them by using a
drone but she instead kills otto
this ship is destroyed by dom but she
does manage to escape
and will no doubt return down the line
at some point in one of the upcoming
films
now mia and dom reconcile with jacob but
because he's a wanted man it means that
he should be taken in
however dom gives him a 10 second call
which is a call back to the first film
and he escapes in this which will likely
allow him to join the team
as one of the quote-unquote family in
the future
even though he is real family now dom
takes his son to the racetrack where
jack died
and this father and son moment hammers
home what it means to be a toreto
and what the name stands for the movie
ends with a barbecue that was actually
shown as part of the super bowl trailer
and it has a lot to take from it now we
didn't know when we saw this that this
would be the ending of the film
but it's quite a nice tribute to brian
aka paul walker
just before little brian says his grace
his wife mia says that brian's coming
and we see his car pull up on the
driveway now i was reading an article by
digital spy that said they think paul
walker might be brought back through
doubles
and cgi but i'm really not sure his
send-off was very
emotional but i don't know if this
entire effect could be pulled off for a
full film
instead i think this is very much the
kind of nods that we will get to him
with the character being mentioned and
teased
but never shown on screen it can be seen
as disrespectful to bring actors back
from the dead to put them into scenes
and personally i believe this is a far
classier way to do it
that allows us to believe the character
is still there now speaking of
characters reuniting
hand comes to and he meets with his old
friends
which i think hints towards the
direction that the series will be going
from now on
they clearly brought ham back for a
reason and it takes center stage and
this is hit home by the post-credits
scene
featuring jason statham aka deckard shaw
now it was thought that when he branched
off into the spin-off land of hops and
shaw
that he wouldn't be entering the main
set of films for quite a while
whilst this is just a cameo it's good to
see that he's made it to fast92
and it definitely sets up what's to come
we catch shaw in an abandoned warehouse
beating the crap out of a punching bag
and it's revealed that someone is
actually inside of it
sure mercilessly continues to beat the
crap out of him even after he offers him
a thumb drive
which probably has all the cheat codes
for grand theft auto on it now han
enters and much to deckard's surprise
he's still alive
for a long time the campaign justice for
han has been ramping up
and i definitely think the next film
will center around them getting into it
with han doing a lot of psychological
things to him however there are a lot of
people out there
that will probably be team sure and yes
i might even be one of them
just don't judge me yeah just don't
judge me i like han as well now saying
that
i really really like hobson shaw and i
kind of think they turned the villain
into an anti-hero
and after he won so many fans around i
think that the smarter direction to take
is to also make him have a side that you
can relate to and potentially this will
be how the film handles his character
however they might even revert back to
him being a villain as justin lim
brought the character into the fold
and he may have his own ideas for him
now when talking to comicbook.com
lin said the following in regards to han
and deckard's rivalry
well i mean all kidding aside han has
lost his love and there's revenge from
his side
he needs that but the question is how
does a person or a man like han enact
his revenge
is it by force or is it psychological is
it emotional
what is it i think that's what i'm
looking forward to is how is that face
off approached
is it traditional so it looks like we
will be getting hand playing four
dimensional chess
as he can't really take on shore hand to
hand
to han now lin did specifically say this
credit scene was put in place to see if
it's what fans want
but i can't see anyone being against
this lin might even have other plans for
han and when discussing whether justice
would be served
he said the following it won't be fully
served there will be other things i feel
should be explored
as this universe expands into other
mediums maybe tv
and when this character gets is to
respect that's when i think
justice for han is served now lynn is
back for the two film finale to the
franchise
and it's gonna be interesting to see
what direction they take it
now as for my thoughts on the film
although it was absolutely ridiculous
but at the same time i really
really liked it there were some moments
where i was kind of taken out of the
film because i was laughing so much
but it also pretty much does everything
so well that you can't be mad at it
things fly by at such a pace it doesn't
really bog itself down
and i don't believe that it takes itself
all that seriously
outside of vin diesel so it's difficult
to get mad at it
heck when you have characters
questioning whether they're invincible
or not
it just makes it fun and i'm actually
really looking forward to seeing it
again
i think the next two films are going to
be great and i've got no doubt
this movie will make bank sure it was it
wasn't anything amazing let's be honest
it's not going to win any oscars
but you know what it was still a fun
popcorn flick
and it gets a seven out of ten now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out upright and have
lucky episode 3 which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
easter eggs so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch after this
without the way thank you for seeing
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace